and how many takes did you do did eight
takes okay so if you if you don't know
the story there's a giant cargo plane
a400 you're hanging off the side of it
and it takes off yeah and then how fast
can you come down like say you go up
well you know if they strap me on the
side of the plane beforehand and then
they start the engines then we taxi then
I go down the runway and I remember
telling the pilot I said listen you know
I got to work with the test pilot I'm a
pilot I love flying airplanes I'm like
look the angle of attack I want to make
sure my legs are hitting against a
fuselage and he was just kind of smiling
me the whole time
and I was like really I needed my my
legs to hit the fuselage because we set
the camera up on the airplane so you see
the ground going away and he said oh
yeah that won't be a problem and then
the first take we're going down the
runway and it was everything to keep my
feet onto the steps because I was almost
slapped against the fuselage going down
the runway we're going so fast and uh oh
my God it was a little intense
there was that momentum there going oh
maybe this wasn't such a good idea